[Music]
this simple shape has thus
rid itself of the unrest of endless
individuation both of its nature element
which only
universal essence is ruled by necessity
but in its existence and activity
is open to contingency
and of the nation which dispersed into
particular spheres of activity
and individual centers of
self-consciousness has an existence
which is manifold in meaning
and activity all this individuation has
got
been got rid of by this simple form and
brought together
into an individuality that is at rest
this individuality is therefore
confronted by the moment of
unrest it the essence is confronted by
self-consciousness for which as the
birthplace of that unrest
nothing remains except to be pure
activity
what belongs to the substance the artist
gave entirely to his work but to himself
as a particular individuality
he gave in his work no actual existence
he could impart perfection to his work
only by emptying himself
of his particularity depersonalizing
himself and rising to the abstraction of
pure
action in this first immediate
production
the separation of the work from his
self-conscious activity is not yet
restored
to their unity the work by itself is not
therefore actually an inspired work
it is a whole only together with its
genesis
the common element in a work of art that
is that it's produced in consciousness
made by human hands is the moment
of the notion existing quad notion which
stands in contrast to the work
and if this notion whether in the shape
of
artist or spectator is unselfish enough
to declare the work of art to be its own
self absolutely inspired and to forget
himself
as performer or as spectator
then against this we must stick to the
notion of spirit which cannot dispense
with the moment of being conscious of
itself
this moment however stands contrasted
with the work because
in this initial duality of itself spirit
gives the two sides they're abstract
contrasted characters of action and of
being a thing
and their return into the unity from
which they proceeded
has not yet come about
paragraph 708 is the beginning
of an important transition that is
happening
in this subsection of religion
in the form of art this uh section the
abstract work of art we're going from
something that is more abstract to
something
that is more concrete you could say but
not concrete
in merely a visual sense or an
individuating sense
but in a spiritual geistic
sense as we're going to see happening in
just a few paragraphs from now
namely 710 708 begins by referring to a
simple shape and we could say well why
talk about a simple shape how is that a
proper transition
from paragraph 707 which began
or actually ended sorry with uh shapes
plural right shapes that only dimly
recall these titans
no longer creatures of nature lucid
ethical spirits as self-conscious
nations
we have a plurality there and that's
going to be
reflected in a plurality being discussed
in terms of those self-conscious nations
so
so what is this simple shape this uh
gestalt that we're dealing with here
well we're going to have to see that
developing through the rest of the
paragraph
first he tells us that it is read itself
of the unrest the unruh right
of endless individuation so
this is important one and like for eins
a process in which it's individuating
itself over and over and over again
right without reaching
a single work of art a single
shape a single structure that can become
the
object of the cult or at least a
differentiated but systematized
pantheon as well so how does it get rid
of this what is it getting rid of he
says both of its
nature elements and we've seen this
being discussed already
which only qua universal essence
is ruled by necessity but
in its existence and activity those are
two
important terms there right in its it's
doing
it's activity it's tete kait but also in
its existence its design
is ruled by contingency so we've got
this this weird kind of
contradiction here the you know
everything that is
natural appears in its essence
in its broad strokes we could say to be
ruled by
necessity no vendi kite it has to be
that way
and yet why does it have to be that way
in this time
in this place in these combinations well
that's total contingency
so we're not getting the necessity that
we we
thought we were getting and we wanted to
have and that can be pointed out by
those who are the artists themselves or
critics of them
and then we move on to another phase
right and we've already seen this
well discussed both in this section and
in the previous section he goes on and
says and of the nation
the people the folk right which
dispersed into particular
spheres of activity and individual
centers of self-consciousness so
spheres of activity moss and just you
know domains we could say
and centers of self-consciousness point
to the points
each person within a particular
institution domain it could even be like
a you know clan
structure or something like that um
occupational
cast whatever it happens to be each
person is a point
of self-conscious activity we've got
this vast differentiation
happening within the ethical nation
that's
being hopefully depicted by
you know the statuary or paintings or
whatever it is that we've got going on
here
he says um these all have an existence
a dozen so again dozen is coming up
which is manifold in meaning
zin right and activity tun in
what it what it signifies and what it
accomplishes what it does what it
intends
so this is all part of endless
individuation and we could say well i
mean it's not
individuation in the sense that within
the ethical
nation every single person is just on
their own we do have these connections
in the
spheres of activity and individuals are
related to each other and similarly in
the
the nature elements whether it be plants
or animals or you know
crystals or whatever they are connected
to each other
but we're not getting um
what's going to come up later this
individuality
at rest and so he says all of this
individuation has been got rid of
by this simple form and brought together
into an individuality
that is at rest now is this
is this again depicting what happened in
the previous paragraph
you know it's hard to see how to fit
these together
that well right the essential being
of the god is what we're looking for
here isn't it but
we wind up with the gods plural
in 707 so he says all this individuation
has been brought
together into an individuality that is
at rest so maybe it's not the
god that's the individuality at rest
maybe it's something
else he says this individuality is
therefore
confronted by the moment of unrest by
opposition it the
essence is confronted by
self-consciousness right
self-consciousness
is comprising here
a unrest that it brings to the process
whose self-consciousness
well we're going to get the artist but
we're also going to get here
talking about the spectator
and can we talk about there being any
self-consciousness in the work of art
not at this point yet as a matter of
fact there's going to be a very
interesting interplay here
so he says it's confronted by the
self-consciousness which as the
birthplace
of that unrest nothing remains except to
be
pure activity what belongs to the
substance
the artist gave entirely to his work and
and now notice this
thing that's taking place this moment
this
transition so what belongs to the
substance the artist gave entirely to
the work the work
is the recipient of the labor
but also the self-conscious thought
the willing of the
artist the person who forms it
he goes on and he says to himself as a
particular individuality
right as this artist the person who is
working with the material who is
developing things
he gave in his work no actual
existence no no
does that mean that there are no traces
i mean the
the most trivial one is the signature of
the artist right
but any artist when they're working upon
materials and creating a work of art if
they are a genuine artist and not just a
copier
not just a varric meister but a quincler
in
in the german terminology that hegel is
using they are imparting something of
their own
creative activity something that
is individuated but here
the more that they the more that they
avoid that
you might say contaminating the artwork
the better the artwork
is going to be and we could ask
ourselves this interesting question
can a genuine artist really avoid doing
that sort of thing he says
the artist could impart perfection to
their work
only by emptying himself of his
particularity depersonalizing himself
rising to the abstraction of pure
action pure doing pure creating
and this is very interesting we have a
dynamic here and this is something that
the german idealists talked quite a bit
about in their
aesthetics this interplay between
particular at particularity
and we could say individuality
especially on the part of the
producer the artist and the
universality involved in the work of art
in a certain sense
the work is a better work the more
universal it is
and the less it is a work by so
and so a work of so and so and yet in
order to bring that
off it requires not only
a great amount of artistry but you might
say a sort of moral recognition
and decision on the part of the artist
to give that to that work of art its
universality without their traces
depersonalizing
themselves in the work taking themselves
while they put themselves entirely into
the work
in one sense taking themselves out of
the work
in another way so he says
in this first immediate production the
separation
of the work from his self-conscious
activity is not yet restored
to their unity the work is by itself
not actually and inspired and bezeled
right not
an animate not a when we see inspired
don't think about divine inspiration in
the sense of uh
genius or you know the guy you know
what we see in plato's iron where the
gods you know blow
something with enthusiasm into the the
poet and the poet thereby produces
as the agent of the god rather think of
this in the other way as the artist
trying to make something
that could be equivalent to his own or
her own self
in having a soul in having
animation to it liveliness as we
talked about uh earlier in in
previous paragraphs right so the work
by itself is not actually an inspired
work what makes it an inspired work he
says it's a whole
a gantz right only together with its
genesis and genesis here is translating
the
german term verden it's coming to be
it's it's becoming so the
artist as worker as producer as
artisan part of the story
of the work of art that gives it its
being and sold is its
retention of connection what we might
call its provenance right
or the marks the indices
by which it retains this connection to
its maker it is not yet
independent on its own
so he says the common element in a work
of art
that is produced in consciousness
and made by human hands is the moment of
the notion
existing qua notion this is very
interesting
if right but if his notion or we could
translate it as concept
and here he doesn't just say the notion
as
notion right the notion quan notion
you know existing as the notion so the
notion
is you could say intensified in this way
the notion
existing standing out as notion
which stanzy says in contrast to the
work and so the notion
is in this weird triangulated space
between those human beings who are
connected with the work one by producing
one by we might say acknowledging using
consuming
which could also include the artist as
well and then we have the work of art
itself and the notion is what is
connecting them but the notion is on the
side of the artist
and as he says the spectator right
it says if this notion whether in the
shape
of artist or spectator is unselfish
enough to declare the work of art to be
in its own self
absolutely inspired and to forget
himself
as performer or spectator then against
this
we must stick to the notion of spirit
which cannot dispense with the moment of
being conscious of itself now that's a
very
interesting sentence there is it not
there's a lot of stuff going on there so
first off
notice that he says the notion could be
in the shape of the artist
or it could be in the shape of the
spectator and then there's a third
option
us right the phenomenologist
who can oppose to either of these and
notice what the
the artist or the spectator can both do
assume the work of art to be inspired
even though
it's not in itself inspired it's being
inspired by
all the other things that are going into
it it's verdan
it's genesis that comes along you could
say
for the ride or as part of its history
so it we should also say wait a second
we've been talking about the artist up
until this point why are we bringing the
spectator in here
well because the spectator is the end
user
the one who is going to worship the
artist could be dead
five generations and yet that statue
that they created
that is within the temple painted uh
the object of cult devotion and you know
festivals and things like that
is still being used by the spectator
so the spectator or the artist can also
forget themselves as performers or
spectators and here's where we do get
something like
the notion of inspiration enthusiasm
rather than merely being animate
the artist can forget themselves in
their activity they can
move on to the next artwork they can
lose so much of themselves in it
the spectator by being part of the
worship
of the image of the the god
can also lose themselves as well
and the work of art can assume
prominence here and then hegel tells us
watch out for this we must stick to the
notion of spirit
what's the notion of spirit well at
least in the religion section
spirit conscious of itself spirit adds
self-consciousness
right so he goes on and he says
this moment stands contrasted with the
work
because in this initial duality of
itself spirit
gives the two sides they're abstracted
contrasted characters of
action and of being a thing
and their return into the unity from
which they proceeded has not yet come
about
so if they do happen to lose themselves
artist or spectator
in the work of art for a while it's
going to fall apart
because both of them are doing
one is doing by acting one is doing
by perceiving by relating itself
in worship and the work of art there
is providing you might say a fixed
artistic
point for religion
the artist then learns in his work that
he did not produce a being like himself
from it it is true there comes back to
him a consciousness in the sense that an
admiring crowd
reveres it as the spirit which is their
own essence
but this inspiration since it returns to
him is self-consciousness
only as admiration is rather a
confession to the artist that the
inspired work is
not on the same level as himself
since his work comes back to him simply
as joyfulness he does not find therein
the painful labor of making himself into
an artist
and of creation nor the strain and
effort of his work
furthermore the crowd may judge the work
or bring it offerings and do it with
their own consciousness and
whatever way it may be if they with
their knowledge set themselves above it
he knows how much more his act is than
what they understand and say if they put
themselves below it and recognize
in at the essence which dominates them
he knows himself
as the master of this being
in paragraph 709 we are
continuing this discussion of this we
could call it
tripolar relation between the
artist the work of art and what in the
previous paragraph hegel called the
spectator
but now in this paragraph we see
no longer just a single spectator but an
admiring
crowd or multitude is another way of
translating it it could even be
translated pejoratively as you know a
mob
or something like that
manga right for it doesn't have a
pejorative connotation to it
they're admiring they're you know seeing
this work of art as something great and
thereby also the artist if they are
attuned to where it's coming from and
there's another thing that's going on
here as well that we
saw the term bezeltha come up in
in the previous section as an adjective
in sold as a literal way of translating
it
animate or we could also translate it as
inspired
right and this inspiration now
is being talked about as a noun
you know and so there's there's a we
could call it a
concentration if not a substantivation
of what what's happening there in terms
of inspiration and asking about
whether in fact the work of art is
inspired so
he goes on and he says the artist learns
in his work he did not produce a being
like himself that is the beginning
and that is also the conclusion of this
section the artist is in a certain sense
above the work of art which in in a way
could be
a failure on the part of the artist
if the goal is to produce an artifact
that would be a sufficient vehicle
for the divine for the god then
if you're left with a statue that you
know is not
a being a vason in this case like the
artist
maybe there's actually a problem here
rather than a success
depends on what the artist is looking
for doesn't it
hegel doesn't really go into this but
perhaps you could have an artist who's
you know all about i want to be the one
who creates
and my works of art none of them should
be equal to me
but in many cases artists at least in
the classic sense they
they want to produce something at least
as good
if not greater than themselves right
so he goes on and he says from it
meaning the work of art it is true there
comes back to him a consciousness
in the sense that an admiring crowd
right the spectator
reveres it as the spirit which is their
own essence and again we see this word
vasen
coming up being essence the work of art
offers that
to the artist who created it and to the
admiring crowd
who is not just looking at it but using
it
as a reference point for their religious
activity so an admiring crowd reveres it
but reveres it as what as the image of
the god who's like so far beyond us
and is you know so much better than us
as in the unhappy consciousness
that we're just miserable worms or crap
in relation to it
no as their own essence i mean here we
are talking about
the ethical folk the ethical people
the ones who identify athena
as their own or poseidon as their own or
apollo
as their own and are happy to have the
statuary in the temple created by the
artists
so uh he goes on and he says this
inspiration
right so here we get bizzelling this
inspiration that's supposed to be
happening here
because it returns to the artist
it returns to them their
self-consciousness
only as admiration is rather a
confession to the artist that the
inspired work is not on the same level
as themself
notice what we're not getting here right
we're getting
admiration is that the same thing as
hegelian
recognition honor kenong it is not
admiration is something that you can
give to an artist you can say oh man
i listen to your albums all the time
you're such an amazing
group and you can send out fan mail and
you can do all these these sorts of
things
but it's not the same thing as being
recognized
being acknowledged by
somebody who would equally be an artist
and can appreciate what you're
doing there aristotle actually picks out
something like this in relation to honor
in nick mccann ethics book one where he
he says do you want to be honored by
everybody no i mean
does it matter if you're being honored
by a whole bunch of people who have no
idea
whether you're actually good at what you
do or a good person or not
no you want to be honored by those who
actually have
something on the ball so to speak and
can say yeah
your work is really good and you're like
oh coming from you
that's really quite important whereas
coming from you know average joe on the
street
or as we used to joke around in french
the the you know
canadian french equivalent to that is
jacques mataras right
uh joe blow he would say in english who
cares what they think
who cares what that admiring crowd
thinks
they might not have much to to offer
right so he says it's a confession to
the artist that the inspired work is not
on the same level
as himself now here he says something
really interesting
since his work comes back to him simply
as joyfulness
freudikite right a
being joyful in having produced the work
of art
there are some things that are not being
represented or reflected here
what in the previous paragraph was
called the genesis
or in in german the vietnam of the work
of art
and there's two things that hegel is
picking out here this
painful labor right
painful labor of of what
of making himself into an artist
building
of cultivating oneself building is an
interesting term here
it means cultivation it also means
shaping
developing right sort of like what's
being done with the work of art but
by the artists to themselves making
themselves into the kind of thing
that could in fact do art
and what else uh end of creation
zoygun right so we've got one side here
the things the artist
has done to themselves to make
themselves into an artist and this could
be a continual
ongoing activity and then there's
the making the work of art the strain
and effort of work
on our bite right
it's not fun to make things
it's a lot of work to produce works of
art
right not only the work that you needed
to get there to even be capable of it
but the work that you have to put into
it and the admiring crowd the audience
the spectators
they often don't know that i was just
reading a book this is a bit of a
digression but i think this gets us
across
about the band van halen long before
they had a record contract
even before they were really making it
in the club scene
the brothers alex and edward van halen
were practicing as a band and whoever
else they happen to have after a while
they got david lee roth
but for a long time they had you know
just a bassist that would sing with them
or you know other other people like that
uh before they got that
they would practice four hours a day
six days a week
and they're working on works of art
sometimes other people's works of art
getting down
cover songs that they would play
sometimes developing their own original
songs
that they were going to play as well
doing it over and over and over again
that's craftsmanship
that's what's required when you see
people doing sculpture
you know it's not like they just did 3d
printing they had the image of it and
all out it comes no they have to chisel
away
over and over again day after day after
day
some paintings take weeks
to to do maybe even months maybe maybe
years none of that is reflected in what
the crowd
even if they watch some biopics or
behind the music or anything
none of that is something that the crowd
can usually appreciate you have to have
some
some involvement in the world of art
yourself in order to get that
he i think hegel would say so he says
the crowd may judge the work or bring in
offerings
and do it with their own consciousness
in whatever way it may be
if they with their knowledge set
themselves above it
the artist knows how much more his act
is than what they understand and say
if they put themselves below it and
recognize in
the essence which dominates them he
knows himself
as the master of this being so whichever
way the crowd goes
placing themselves above or below the
work of art
the artist knows themself
to be above both the crowd and the work
of art
and so we're replaced here again with
a kind of conundrum what kind of art
were we
aiming at were we in aiming at an insole
inspired
art if that's the case then
the visual plastic arts that we've been
working with
are not adequate to that task
you